skechers skechers, no team just
comfort. Tonight. Putin at war
with his own people, arresting
another popular Russian activist
who says he met with the wall
Street journal reporter Evan
Herskovits right before
gershowitz was arrested. This is
video of yaroslav search Jakob
being detained at his home video
of him. They they've taken him
into custody. He is officially
accused of justifying terrorism
. Those the words after he wrote
that he didn't quote feel a
shadow of sadness. About the
death of a pro war blogger, the
one who was killed in that
bombing at a St Petersburg cafe
earlier this month. If I was
also one of the first people to
sound the alarm on gorshkov
itches arrest. So now this
latest arrest comes almost three
weeks to the day that Herskovits
himself was arrested today for
the first time since then we saw
him in public. He appeared in
the Russian courtroom, which
meant that he was inside a cage
. This was a glass cage. There.
He is dressed in a shirt and
jeans. That's all we saw of him.
At today's hearing, a judge
rejected the Americans request
to be placed under house arrest,
which means that he is going to
continue being locked up inside
of one of Russia's most
notorious jails. The lefortovo
prison. Earlier we spoke to the
fiancee of another journalist
who was held there at lefortovo
even saffron off. He was
arrested in July. 2020 accused
of disclosing state secrets. So
for months he was held at
lefortovo, then he was sentenced
to 22 years. His fiancee tells
us that the conditions there in
that prison where Evan Gorski,
which is tonight are brutal.
It's a terrible place, actually,
um. The light is on the whole
time. They have a shower once a
week. Um rooms there are it's
like maybe three or four M. Um
they have no opportunity to walk
. Normally they cannot see son
were to feel winds. Um in the
fourth of a nobody usually has
some dates with their families
or some phone calls with their
partners or families. Just to
think about that. And keep in
mind that many at that prison,
you know, like ceviche haven't
even been convicted yet, right?
This is how they're treated for
the months and years prior to
any sort of a trial, and you can
only imagine the conditions that
they then face afterwards.
Something that one top Putin
critic is experiencing horribly
tonight. Vladimir cameras up. He
was sentenced to 25 years in
prison in Russia yesterday, his
crime was speaking out against
Putin's war in Ukraine and
joining me out front. Now if you
have any cameras or Vladimir
cameras as wife and Jenny, I'm
glad to see you again. I'm so
sorry about the horrible
circumstances that we have to
talk in. Now have you even been
able to process what has
happened here? What this means
for your family. Hello, Aaron.
It's good to see you again. Um
well, you know, um, I think I
haven't been able to process
what's happening for a while. I
don't. Um, I don't think I can
afford processing all of it
right now, because if I do I am
afraid that I will collapse. I
will fall into a million pieces
and I understand that I cannot
afford this. I have to fight on.
So I leave by the quote of
Winston Churchill, who said if
you go through hell, keep going.
You know you last time we spoke
, you talked about what your
husband has suffered the health
issues that he has gone through
since he was twice poisoned. And
yesterday when I spoke to his
attorney, vadim he told me that
the sentence amounts to a death
penalty to Vladimir because he's
so worried about the health
challenges that he faces. Do you
share this fear? Unfortunately I
do light America's health has
deteriorated drastically in
detention. For years he'd been
able to keep those polling
neuropathy symptoms. That loss
of feeling in his extremities
through physical exercise about
a year in pretrial detention,
and then sometimes that he spent
in sultry confinement were
enough to bring not only bring
back those symptoms for them to
spread to his right side, so he
is now losing feeling both his
feet. And his left hand this
diagnosis falling europa. These
can lead to paralysis. And I
understand that in in a Russian
prison, he will obviously not
have access to any problem
medical care. So I am afraid
that the Russian authorities are
trying to kill him yet again for
the third time in eight years.
Jenny, what else do you think
could be done? I mean, I know
that he is a dual citizen,
Russian and British. Um do you?
Is there more the uk can do. I
mean, what more could be done at
this point? Um he's also a green
card holder in the United States
and I have been trying to get
him determined as unlawfully
detained. Because onto the
Levingston act. He um he while
he meets all the criteria um, I
believe that it is very
important for the free world to
stand with freedom fighters
alike. Um all those people who
are standing out against the
regime and risking not only the
freedom but very often their
lives, and I believe that if
that advocacy it could be
conducted in the soviet times
when a relationship when the
relationship with the soviet
union was obviously far from
being a very good it can
definitely be done now because
when it becomes a question of
life and death, everything
should be done to save a
person's life. Yes indeed you
have Jenny. I'm I'm grateful to
be able to speak to you. My